[Música]
i
buenas noches noches gracias por
invitación así es
hemos conversado esta tarde noche sobre
todo lo que ha hecho la destrucción
tecnológica en el sistema financiero y
para las entidades financieras ha sido
un reto muy interesante
hay un punto que ni la tecnología ni lo
que hace el día a día significa otro
reto para las entidades financieras y es
el cambio climático
tomando en cuenta esto como un riesgo es
momento de actuar ya
bueno vamos a ver el tema del cambio
climático se ha ido popularizando por
así decir pero claro hasta que queda un
largo camino para
de asimilar
y aceptar
lo que el cambio climático significa en
diferentes secciones de la sociedad y
actividades bueno una de ellas es el
sector financiero en la dificultad
principal que existe aquí es de que los
intermedios financieros tienen carteras
de crédito que se hicieron antes de que
los peligros o los retos del cambio
climático estuvieron presentes y
entonces ahora esas carteras tienen que
están funcionando cuando los riesgos del
cambio climático se están dando entonces
ahí hay una dificultad y sé que no hay
responsabilidad ni de los quienes
obtuvieran los créditos ni quienes los
concedieron porque en ese momento no
existían esos riesgos
aprieto ahora la dificultad es cómo van
a administrar a los entidades
financieros
el manejo de una cartera que en cuanto a
plazos en cuenta todos los intereses en
cuanto a garantías
no tenían incluidos los riesgos que el
cambio climático nos puede presentar
tomador de se me está tocando el tema de
los riesgos curiosamente hace
prácticamente un de casi un año verdad
que tuvimos el tema de un huracán que
tocó el país
ni de una forma completa mucha gente no
estaba preparado al respecto cuáles son
esos principales riesgos que afectaría
el sistema financiero este tema del
cambio climático pero el riesgo es que
el cambio climático va a modificar
significativamente toda la estructura
normal de la producción nacional todos
los sectores de la del país la
con un énfasis que quieren los que están
en campo agrícola el campo ganadero pero
también en el campo de todo lo que es la
utilización de suelos urbanos todo lo
que se refiere a energías y transportes
todos esos sectores van a ver afectados
por el cambio climático bueno eso es lo
que quiere decir que los bancos que
tienen una cantidad importante o no
tienen casi la totalidad de sus créditos
en esos sectores de esos sectores se van
a ver con dificultades para poder
cumplir los compromisos que tiene con
los bancos para pagarles a tiempo de
acuerdo con las condiciones originales
de los créditos pagarles a tiempo a
tiempo eso le va a producir a los center
medios financieros problemas en sus
flujos de caja porque no van a poder
recibir lo que ellos suponían que iban a
recibir a los bancos a la vez tienen que
hacerle frente a sus pasivos y ahí se
puede implementar
dificultades pero no solamente el flujo
de cajas haber afectado ahora el balance
situación también se verá afectado y se
va a ver afectado por un lado porque a
este lado de los ingresos el problema
que tiene los bancos es que su cartera
de crédito se ha mejorado a ahí tiene un
problema con los pasivos el banco ha y
por otro lado tiene un problema también
que tiene que ver con los activos porque
muchos de los activos que han recibido
en garantía van a disminuir de precio
porque van a estar localizados ubicados
en zonas que van a ser afectadas por el
cambio climático van a estar ahí en los
bancos y consiguientemente normalmente
el flujo de caja y el balance situación
les afecta la rentabilidad o las
utilidades que tienen los bancos y esto
plantea desde el punto vista nacional
una dificultad porque el país es
necesita que el sector financiero
funcione adecuadamente todos los
sectores viven en gran parte de la
presión de operaciones de crédito y
claro está que el desarrollo económico
en general del país es indispensable yo
soy pro financiero funcione bien y ese
es un reto que tiene explicación de cómo
va a administrar esa situación claro
está que el cambio climático no
solamente produce problemas
sino toda crisis tiene también
posibilidades nuevas posibilidades y
nuevas oportunidades y perdón que para
poder hacer un poco el contexto de estas
oportunidades
digamos que ellos estaban conversando
los pasados por ahí está sobre todo las
oportunidades que generaron este tema de
la erupción tecnológica aplicativos
nuevos sistemas de transacción
cuestiones que vienen a futuro como el
block change
qué situaciones de oportunidad ve usted
para el sistema financiero en esto no
solamente de la perspectiva bancaria
sino también puede ser de seguros de
inversión de cuestiones directamente que
tienen que ver con el riesgo bueno
hay muchas nuevas oportunidades
originadas también en el cambio
climático
cosas como por ejemplo en el campo
agrícola bueno esto lo que va a
significar es de que algunos riesgos van
acompañados también con oportunidades ay
ay ay estos son las regiones del país en
donde va a llover
más de lo que yo veo anteriormente el
que anteriormente nos daban créditos
porque en esa zona no era la próxima
agrícola no se podía desarrollar ahora
con el cambio climático a algunas zonas
del país van a tener menos
lluvias y nosotros van a tener más
lluvias la variabilidad de las lluvias y
la intensidad va a ser diferente a eso
crea problemas pero crea también
oportunidades hay oportunidades también
en desarrollos tecnológicos que vienen
con el cambio climático como es el
automóvil eléctrico
como son cambios en la matriz de energía
con energías limpias
todos esos son oportunidades que se van
abriendo y que todas ellas requieren
financiamiento entonces los bancos y
pues de ahora en adelante en start o que
incorporen en sus estrategias y en su
superación los riesgos que significa el
cambio climático ir formando una cartera
que ya tome en cuenta el cambio
climático pero entonces esta transición
que tienen que ser de como mejor una
cartera que en la práctica tiene más
riesgos de lo que los bancos suponían y
otra cartera en que ya ese tipo de
riesgos está
no digamos controlado es el malabarismo
que va a tener que hacer las ventas
financieros claro hasta que toda la
revolución tecnológica que hemos oído es
muy útil porque permite con la nueva
información que vamos a recibir los
robots este este tipo de se reten luego
a los bancos a calcular mejor los
problemas que van a tener con la cartera
actual y le van a permitir verdad de que
hacerle frente y evitar o administrar
mejor los riesgos desde la nueva cartera
claro por supuesto y así me lo se
disculpe y así me lo dice teniendo dos
reguladores acá en estas presentaciones
cómo se va a hacer esa medición del
cambio climático es algo que es
complicado porque no puede uno prever
tan fácilmente las situaciones que dan
aunque ya cualquiera ve y dice que el
cambio que el clima como tal es muy
diferente mes a mes verdad como va
sucediendo en los últimos años pero como
pasa en las discusiones financieras como
tal cómo hacerlo por medio de seguros
por medio de alguna otra forma de
activos por alguna reserva cómo se
genera en este tipo de circunstancias
de cambio climático bueno hemos dado
casi sólo los bancos pero hay otros
intermedios en el cierre como las
compañías de seguros que también tienen
un problema complicado en frente de
ellos porque una cartera que tiene no
vendía las primas que calcularon como
unos riesgos
posiblemente no deben armar una y tienen
que recalcular entonces algunas primas
son re negociadores pero otras no
claro está que en todo el esquema de
seguros es un elemento que es importante
pero no fundamental va a ser de que los
bancos incorporen y cuando hablamos de
las acciones de las cosas prioritarias
que me parece a mí que existen es la
urgencia de que los bancos
en su gobernanza incluyan en sus
estrategias de mediano plazo el problema
del riesgo climático así como tiene
incluidos e incorporados otros tipos de
riesgos y en la parte puramente
operativa también es necesario de que
los diques los bancos
incorporen
capaciten personal si los que esto le
van a dar a el personal y que compren
robots que incluyen esta estos nuevos
riesgos si lo que van a dar son
préstamos que a través de la nutrición
de sus operaciones claro por supuesto y
para la percepción al público al
consumidor al productor que quien retos
pero también en este tema financiero
conforme a lo que es el cambio climático
bueno ahí lo que vamos a tener es que
clientes de los bancos son a encontrar
un banco le va a decir bueno mire señor
ya donde yo los financia usted para
sembrarlos ya no lo puedo financiar para
sembrar ronda tal vez lo puedo no puedo
financiar para sembrar otra cosa pero
pero ahí plantar los bancos van a tener
que protegerse
y la información del cambio climático es
importante yo no sé si la historia a
través de un pick but tendrá está le
pueden servir la porque los riesgos que
no se han dado y parte a una dificultad
técnica que puedo ver ahí es que no se
puede que no existe todavía big data
sino que hay que irla acumulando
conforme el cambio climático y hay un
tema que habría que terminar como cómo
se puede resolver la que esperaría usted
que esto es algo que es de hoy o será
paulatino en el futuro que se haya
desarrollando acciones directamente de
las entidad financieras y el sistema
bueno el cambio climático tiene 22
características que me parece muy
importante de que no es algo para un
futuro distante sino que ya lo tenemos
ya se comienzan a ver algunos cambios
que se supone que son resultado del
cambio climático y esto ayer en
creciendo y la otra cosa es de que el
cambio climático no es un fenómeno
transitorio pasajero que no puede decir
bueno
recibimos palo durante un par de años
pero esto se va a resolver para efectos
prácticos en el cambio climático es algo
permanente desde ese punto de vista
tenemos que organizando ahora las
entidades que son en cuanto a los
centros en términos financieros privados
ahora la superintendencia con así si el
banco central tienen a iones response
es importante porque también la
regulación y la supervisión para jugar
un papel importante no se trata de
ahogar a los intermedios financieros con
nuevas regulaciones sino a adaptar la
regulación negra a un riesgo o un
conjunto de riesgos que no existían
hasta hasta el momento perfecto un tema
que sería tan trascendental para los
tomadores de decisiones es qué papel
jugará en este caso el banco central
usted como ex banquero central este
referente a lo que son las informaciones
de la economía de costa rica lo que
significa para el déficit fiscal lo que
significa para todo lo que son los
números macroeconómicos del país siendo
el banco quién es el que desarrolla
todos estos números que significa qué
valor y qué peso deberían de tener en
esos números el banco central ya tiene
una una comisión interdepartamental que
está examinando precisamente el tema del
cambio climático y supone que eso se va
a multiplicar en un futuro cercano la
subred supervisión y regulación está
sobre todo en manos de una cifra es
sorprendente pero el banco tiene un
interés clave y fundamental en esto que
no quiere que tener una crisis que se
originen en el sector financiero es si
los bancos no administran bien absoluto
la cartera existente ante un nuevo
entorno riesgo pero una última pregunta
donde
estamos preparados para lo que significa
el impacto del cambio climático como
sociedad costarricense en lo económico
no creo que tenemos organizados todavía
en ningún campo
para eso se van a requerir ciertas ni de
legislativas se van a requerir crear
instituciones o modificar instituciones
actualmente se va a requerir capacitar
personal tanto en ese producto y dado
como en el sector público porque todo
eso es un proceso que esperemos que se
pueda poder avanzar por lo menos el
ritmo que va avanzando y las
consecuencias de lectura del cambio
climático perfecto muchas gracias muchas
gracias